So, recall that we just said that people respond differently to stress. And one
of the things that determines this difference in how people respond to stress,
is how positively or negatively they see the world. So, certainly you've all
heard the term optimist and pessimist. Now, the optimist, as the saying goes,
will see this glass as half full and the pessimist will see it as half empty.
So, optimism is good, not just for our behavior, but for our minds and our
bodies as well. So, for instance, research has shown that optimists are less
likely to get depressed. They're better able to cope with their emotions, and
they recover faster from, and cope better with stress. So, optimism is good for
our minds and our bodies.